Today, we boarded a ferry to Gorée Island which is just off the coast of Senegal.
Now for roughly 300 years until the mid-1840s,...
...millions of men, women, and children from Africa...
...were kidnapped from their homes and communities...
...and brought to this island to be sold as slaves.
Now on the island, we saw cells...
...where dozens of people were packed together for months on end.
We saw the courtyard where they were forced to stand naked...
...while buyers examined them, negotiated a price,...
...and bought them as if they were nothing but property.
There is no way to undo what happened on Gorée Island,...
...and no way to erase the stain of slavery from our nation's past.
But there is also no denying the course that history has taken since that time.
Since then, we've seen so many brave men and women rise up against slavery...
...and segregation and injustice and inequality of all kinds.
People who came through this island could never have imagined how history would unfold...
...and they certainly could never have imagined that someone like me,...
...a descendant of slaves, would come here and look back through that door of no return.